il ya deux choses d'abord concernant les
soignants il est évident que c'est quand
même une très bonne nouvelle pour les
patients en particulier
c'est vrai qu'on est nous déjà en tant
que soignant des obligations dans les
médecins d'éviter le mexique sont
obligatoires comme pour l'hépatite b
donc je dirais que c'est un prince qui
aime normalement et épandre et on
devrait même pas se poser la question de
savoir si longtemps le soignant de
vacciner ou non
ce qui est hallucinant la vraisemblable
c'est que encore 40% des soignants dans
les maisons dans les ehpad maisons par
action donc je dirais qu'il ya quand
même un problème je rappelle qu'on a une
liberté et comme disait que mou bien sûr
le 14 heures mais on a aussi les
obligations n'at on a des choses à faire
on vit pas je dirais seul dans son coin
voilà il ya plus de société il ya un
tauren qui existe parce qu'elle a
on peut aussi rouler tous à 250 euros
100 km sur autoroute soit s'occuper les
voisins il faut être raisonnable
je trouve que concernant la partie
vaccination des soignants c'est très
bien